ce que propose le groupe socialiste sera
proposé notre collègue député c'est de
dire retrouvons et insufflons une âme
nouvelle et ne confions pas simplement
EDF qui est le moteur de la Sauveur
intelle énergétique du pays nous leur
confions pas à une élite quel que soit
sa qualité quel que soit les grands
comités
et la souveraineté énergétique du pays a
une élite à une techno structure qui ne
fait qu'une seule chose c'est de dire je
me soumets
le thermifore
je veux pas reprendre ce qui est pu être
écrit de manière affreuse en littérature
on se soumet et j'avoue et je m'adresse
à Gérard Longuet notre excellent
collègue
j'ai été personnellement
malheureux de voir que le consensus
qu'on aurait pu trouver on n'a pas su le
trouver une occasion manquée de dire que
la nationalisation l'Europe quelque part
c'est pas son affaire il y a une sorte
de neutralité technologique bien
neutralité juridique que le monopole
soit public ou privé c'est pas le
problème de l'Europe c'est pas son
problème son problème c'est l'ouverture
du marché et j'ai inventé une chose
absolument affreuse mais très belle en
sémantique qui consiste à dire s'il y a
un monopole monopole de fête ou monopole
juridique et bien il faut simplement que
le marché soit ouvert et qu'il soit donc
contestable la contestabilité donc à la
limite c'est pas le problème de l'eau
c'est un problème national et chaque
propose Philippe Brun mais c'est
précisément d'avoir une arme nationale
nationaliser EDF c'est réarmer la France
nationaliser EDF faire de RDF une
entreprise
verticalement intégré d'intérêt général
et d'intérêt national ça équivaut un
ministère de la défense c'est la défense
de la France ce que on n'a pas su faire
on passe à côté au motifs d'idéologie
qu'il faut faire la tarification au coût
marginal qu'il faut corréler le prix de
l'électricité à la dernière unité mise
en œuvre à savoir du lignée tout
peut-être du charbon allemand mais c'est
ça malheureusement le problème et quand
on veut descendre pour l'usage des
Français pour le plus grand bien des
Français de dire il faut interve qui
soit à la disposition de tous non on
change le mode de calcul et c'est le
cours d'approvisionnement du fournisseur
alternatif qui n'a de fournisseur que le
nom c'est ça aujourd'hui le modèle qui
est soumis et auquel nous nous
soumettons tous je le regrette vraiment
il nous faut un champion national il
faut donc la nationalisation d'EDF avec
défense des intérêts de la France il
faut
délimiter le périmètre pour éviter les
sessions il faut un tr- revue et corrigé
et voilà ce que nous remettons pas
amendement dans le texte qui vous est